hello thank you for that introduction
so I'm Julie I manage the health data
science team at Twitter and if you've
ever been on the opposite end of a
hiring manager interview with me you
know that when we talk about health at
Twitter we're talking about our anti
abuse anti-spam and anti misleading
information efforts but also pro the
good things that keep Twitter
interesting and a compelling platform I
want to thank the potato organizers for
asking me to speak and when they first
reached out I was a little confused I'm
still fairly early in my career so a
little over five years ago I was sitting
in a 17th floor of our LM trying to deal
with the existential crisis that arises
when you ask yourself so what actually
happens after I finished writing this
thesis and so I thought that this might
be a good opportunity to sort of
demystify what it's like to do data
science and to speak to my experiences
to show that it's not that scary it's
not that mysterious and and it's a lot
of really cool impactful work that you
can do so like any good data scientist I
would like to set a baseline and to
provide the context from which I am
sharing these experiences so as I said I
got my PhD from the University of Texas
where I studied the chemical composition
of the oldest observable stars in our
galaxy grad school was a really
challenging and interesting experience
for me part of which being due to the
fact that in my incoming class there
were 10 of us and I was the only woman
and towards the end of grad school many
of us were really feeling that academia
wasn't the place for us but I had spent
a lot of time feeling kind of isolated
from the rest of my classmates and so
their notions of data sciences this
thing that they wanted to do didn't
really resonate with me and so my
response was to try something different
so I went to a coding boot camp called
hack write Academy hack ride Academy is
aimed at increasing the number of women
and non-binary folks in tech and the way
that the boot camp runs which is I'm
guessing similar to galvanize is the
first half is coursework and then the
second half you do approach
I was very convinced there would not be
a data scientist so I did an
unsupervised machine learning project
that I snuck into a flask app and
therefore it was a website at the end
they introduced you to different
companies and you do interviews with
these companies and so one of the
companies that I interviewed with asked
me to interview with their data science
team in addition to their developer team
and I was confused and like but I just
spent 10 whole weeks learning how to be
a web developer they like put that PhD
makes us think that you could also be a
data scientist so I ended up getting an
offer for both positions as a developer
and it's a data scientist and the
developer role was to start with CSS and
work your way towards the back of the
stack and if anybody knows me here
personally I am not organized enough to
think well in CSS so that seems like a
bad idea or I'm the data science side I
could solve really interesting problems
around entity resolution and and
attribution questions in the ad tech
space so I decided to become a data
scientist and it was a really good
decision for me for a number of
different reasons and I think one of the
most critical components of that was my
manager my manager was a former
physicist and so he knew kind of the
world that I was coming from and he
provided a really nice landing spot
between academia and industry because
they are very different and one of the
ways in which he really encouraged me to
like get introduced to industry to
understand different patterns of how
people engage and interact and and just
meet more people who weren't thinking
about you know like stars for for a
little bit he he encouraged me to go to
meetups and conferences so I kept going
to the PI lady's meetups because like I
need pathan from this this boot camp and
there weren't very many Fortran meetups
in San Francisco at the time and so I
went and like they were interesting it
was like this is a sweat framework or
this is like this thing that does this
other thing and there's some
infrastructure stuff and I was like so
when are you gonna do the data science
talks I'm just like waiting it's like I
know that there's a Kentucky side pie
stack and people have been using like
pandas and
that live and I want to hear leaking
more about that and finally they threw
it back at me and they're like well why
don't you work a nice one and I was like
good question why don't I and so I just
kept asking enough questions and finally
I became an organizer and so I put on a
few different data science events and
they just took because people are really
really excited about data science right
and so right now I live here so I'm no
longer an organizer for pi ladies SF but
the data science component of Pi ladies
is still really strong in the San
Francisco branch I have a similar story
with the Syfy conference and that I went
to my first CyHi conference in 2015 and
I looked around and they were like hmm I
just spent like 10 weeks with like a
whole core cohort of women but like
there didn't seem to be that many women
around and so I kept asking the
organizers for diversity statistics and
like what they were doing to try to like
increase the number of women and folks
for minoritized backgrounds at the
conference and finally they asked me
well why don't you just become diversity
chair and so is diversity chair from
2016 to 2018 and it was amazing to watch
just how not even that much intentional
effort could vastly improve the
experience and the inclusivity of a
conference that is so meaningful to so
many people eventually I moved on from
my first company and made my way to
Twitter where I started out as an
individual contributing data scientist
became a tech lead and then got into
management like many people do so I keep
saying data science but like data
science means so many different things
to so many different people it depends
on who you ask the time of day
what company they're currently at and
and it's kind of just like this wide
open term but I do think that there are
certain things that tie data science
together as as a field so like a little
Side Story I have a seven-year-old
daughter she goes to hello Elementary
but before before we moved to Texas we
were trying to figure out where to send
her to school and so we were about to
put her in kindergarten and we were
trying some can you
classrooms and I walked into one of the
classrooms and I saw this bulletin board
and it's what scientists do and that
scientists communicate information they
make observations they look for patterns
they ask questions they support their
ideas with evidence they use math they
make and use models they do
investigations they get information from
lots of different sources and this is a
really good distillation of what
scientists do but I would also argue
that this is like one of the bestest
solutions I've ever seen of what data
scientists do data scientists do all of
these different things but but in a
really specific context and what I
really like about this is that this is
so simple that a kindergartener is
supposed to be able to understand this
right and so even though like how data
science manifests a different company
can change it does stick to these sort
of core functions of data science as a
role in data science is exciting why do
I even bother understanding this so if
you look at this chart this is the
Google search trends over time so
starting in 2004 almost no one was
looking at data science and it's been
steadily increasing ever since let's say
20 2012 ish or so when you go to
Glassdoor if you look for the 50 best
jobs in america for 2019 it's data
scientist and I've given a similar talk
to this like over the years and I can
keep pointing this and I just update the
year because like it's been number one
for the last four years I think
similarly on LinkedIn if you look at
this the the most promising jobs in the
US for 2019 data scientist was number
one I guess I would rather be a LinkedIn
data scientist and a Glassdoor one since
a medium base salary is higher in
LinkedIn the other thing I want to point
out since this is PI data is that if you
look at the related topics you have
Python for free data science and you
don't see some other things
cool so what does data science look like
at Twitter so at Twitter we have a
consumer data science organization and
when you think of Twitter the app your
home timeline your notifications your
DMS somebody and the consumer data
science auric is likely done an analysis
or run an experiment or created a model
to better understand that surface area
or that product to make the best
decisions for our users and so we have
teams that cover many different areas so
user behavior and growth like what our
users doing and what are the things that
compel them to come back to the platform
and what are the things that convince
new users to join understanding our
top-line company metrics is like part
part of this as well we also have teams
that are dedicated to understanding what
content gets created and who consumes
them and most importantly how do we
connect those folks creating this really
engaging vibrant exciting content and
and tie those folks to the people who
really want to see that information we
have a team that is dedicated to
experimentation and it's not just
running a be test but it's really
helping us define how we view
experimentation as a company and to to
know that we are making the best let's
say statistical decisions when we're
running these these experiments we have
a data visualization team and their
twitter handle is at Twitter data and if
you go to interactive chat twitter.com
you can see some of the work that
they've published and it's super cool
because like they are able to take the
power of the firehose and all of Twitter
data and display it in ways that are
compelling and engaging and and just fun
so if you're a big fan of Game of
Thrones highly recommend checking that
out and then finally we have a health
data science team and I'll talk a lot
more about that because this is my team
and this is the lens through which I
have experienced and driven data science
at scale so let's step back a little bit
so why does health data science matter
so this stone is one of the cofounders
of Twitter and on January 24th first he
tweeted we serve the public conversation
and so what does that mean what what
does it mean to be public what
Twitter should be a public space Twitter
should be a place where everybody feels
open to share their ideas opinions
information and and for people to
converse with each other right but it's
really hard to do that if you feel like
you don't belong or you feel like it's
not safe for you to do so so the health
data science team works closely with the
Health Organization and this is our team
charter so we work with a health
organization to hashtag fix the internet
to make data-driven decisions through
research and analysis innovations around
metrics and methods experimentation and
more to ensure that Twitter is a safe
and informative experience for our
customers this is like a lot and like
it's pretty like lofty right but I want
to kind of get into some examples of
what does this really actually mean
because I think like with a lot of
things in data science or tech in
general people talk about stuff at a
really high level without actually
detailing like what does it mean to do
this day to day so what do we do so we
are involved in goal-setting and
prioritization we want to make sure that
when engineering product design user
research decide that this project is
really important that it's actually
something that will keep users safe not
just because people intuitively think
that it should matter but because we
have the data to back that up because
any of these efforts aren't free they
take time they take they cost
engineering hours it cost product hours
and and it's possible that they won't
work and so we want to be as sure as
possible that this is something that is
worth investing in we do a lot of
opportunity sizing and prototyping so
somebody has an idea to fix part of a
problem and so like how many users do we
think that this will impact and to what
degree is this a really a big problem or
is it something that is like maybe like
less less severe and and we have to make
these trade-offs all the time do you go
for something that is like the most
severe but maybe only affects a few
people or do you go for something that's
like more widely like unliked but like
affects much more many more people and
so we work really closely with folks and
product and policy to try to make these
decisions and to try to help give them
as much information as possible so they
can make the best judgments that they
possibly can we do a lot of
experimentation
Twitter in general and experimentation
in the health space is interesting
because there are ethical implications
if there's something that we think truly
helps our users be safer or get better
information then who are we to keep that
from them that's not to say that we
never do experiments because sometimes
we're not sure and we need to run this
experiment to really see what the impact
is to see if it's worth it and so it
means that we have to come up with novel
ways of doing a/b tests for safety
features it means that we need to be
integrated into the rest of the product
surface areas not just within health but
across the platform because sometimes
you have something that might increase
logins or something that like might
increase the number of tweets created
but it also measurably reduces the
safety of the platform for our users and
so it's really important for us to have
these kind of a cross-functional
collaborations to to drill into that and
to understand what we're really doing
for and to our users when we make
changes we also do impact analyses so
kind of getting back to the the point of
sometimes it's just not achill to do
these experiments when we come up with a
new policy like my favorite example fake
example is like Twitter is a bird
company and we know that cats are bad
for birds so if we decide that cat
content on the platform is just the
worst and we need to get rid of it who
are we to only enforce up for part of
the population because there's no way to
truly understand the impact of something
because the network effects that happen
for instance but also from like a sort
of like empathy to our user standpoint
it's just not fair right and so we need
to sometimes be able to just move
quickly without having to do an
experiment and then but but that doesn't
mean that we don't want to understand
how it works right and so that's where
impact analyses and more correlational
analyses come come into play and then
one of the things that we've been doing
a lot to see our product metrics and
investigations so how do we measure the
health of Twitter and it's a really big
question because part of the problem
with health or abuse or whichever way
you want to look at it it's it's latent
it's not something where you can go out
and count the number of logins or you
can count the number of
clicks or you can see how much ad
revenue is generated it's something
completely different and sometimes it's
subjective it's a feeling how our users
feeling and how do you measure that and
how do you make sure that you're
measuring it in a way that is
reproducible and so what happens when we
see these metrics and when we see these
metrics move and what are the things
that we should be doing to again ensure
that users have feelings of safety and
can get to the information that they
really want so I'm gonna walk through a
few different kind of high-level
examples of initiatives that we take in
so one of the biggest initiatives that
we've had is reducing the visibility of
potentially a piece of content so we've
have different surfaces like within the
platform where we will take content that
we believe to potentially be abusive and
to move it to lower visibility so that
way users know you can click here but
there are dragons and this is your
choice to look at them where people who
are maybe more casually browsing really
don't need to see this content that they
they don't want and the ways in which
data science have engaged in this are to
try to figure out how do you measure
this and how do you actually figure out
where the line is between something
that's potentially abusive and something
that's like probably okay and and it's
required a lot of iteration and testing
because it's a very subjective kind of
feeling that that users have that we're
trying to proxy into we also have
something called the quality filter the
quality filter takes all the app
mentions that you get and makes a
decision as to whether or not we will
show you a notification that you've been
at mentioned by someone and a lot of app
mentions are sort of drive-by or abusive
at mentions or drive-bys people that you
don't know people who are at mentioning
you and saying something really terrible
and then moving on and so by suppressing
those notifications you don't have to
see something that you don't want to see
and what we found is that this led to a
40% reduction in blacks following app
mentions from people who you don't
follow so somebody that you haven't
opted in to their their engagement and
interact
we also have taken steps to stop
potential abuse in its tracks so we have
something that like people have deemed
the timeout and so when we see users are
posting a lot of abuse of content over a
short period of time we will take users
and we will limit their account
functionality meaning that they can
tweet but we will be not sent will not
be sending notifications to people who
do not follow them and what we saw was
this limited functionality ended up in
25% fewer abuse reports on those users
so like we were able to reduce like the
an and and mitigate the amount of abuse
these these accounts where we're
propagating on the platform I think the
other thing that's really interesting
here is that of the accounts that are
put into this timeout 65% of them are
put in a timeout once so it's not just
about remediation but it's also about
rehabilitation and users can see like
you can't just take your bad mood out on
the Internet in ways that you maybe want
to we've also developed a suite of user
controls so users can control who they
get notifications from and so you can
choose to not receive notifications from
particular sets of people so people who
you don't follow people who don't follow
you
people who have brand-new accounts
people who have just created an account
and they have never changed their their
profile photo and then other users who
haven't necessarily completely shared
who they are with Twitter itself
similarly you can mute content so you
can mute words that show up in your home
timeline and in your notifications I
think kind of one of the funniest
stories around this is that this isn't
just good for abuse although we have
done a lot of work to understand like
victims of abuse they do use this
feature and they do use this feature for
abuse of words but this was launched
around the same time as the Gilmore
Girls revival and Gilmore Girls ended up
being one of the top muted keywords
during that time period so this has
multiple purposes health is good for
everyone
and then the last kind of high level
thing I want to talk about is our
reporting system so users are allowed
and encouraged to report content that
they think is in violation of our Terms
of Service but one of the things that is
true is that users are not great at
really understanding our rules my
favorite example of this is we have a
private information part of our Terms of
Service and you can't reveal private
information about people so one of the
reports that I've seen come in under
private information was at so-and-so
farts in his sleep and like if I find it
in my sleep I would not want the entire
Internet to know that it's true but
that's not actually what we mean by
private information we're talking about
daxing and so we want to make sure that
like the reports that do come in that
truly are about violative content are
ones that we can put in front of a human
agent so they can review because another
thing that is very true about abuse is
that it's very context dependent and so
having a human in the loop really helps
ensure that like we have the correct
context around like the tweet and the
interaction to understand if it did
truly violate our Terms of Service so we
worked with the machine learning team
and we developed machine learning models
to predict which reports we believed
were actual violations of our Terms of
Service and so we use those to
prioritize which reports actually get
shown to human agents and in which order
all of these efforts are just kind of
attacking parts of the problem because
as it turns out like there are lots of
bad actors on the Internet
and and they all use different methods
and so you have to have an ensemble of
methods to try to fight against this
especially because like abuse and spam
and just basically anti a safety on the
Internet is a really adversarial space
and it's something where we need to as a
company keep growing and evolving and
this is where data science comes in we
need to like help the company really
understand like the different
attack record vectors and the different
trends that we were seeing to try to
help our partners in engineering and
product on policy come up with the new
rules and like the new systems to to
really make user safer so overall like
we've seen 16 percent fewer abuse
reports after an interaction from an
account where the reporter doesn't
follow we've seen three times more
abusive accounts that are suspended
within 24 hours after their first
reported than the year before and more
than 50% of the abuse of content that is
enforced is proactively surfaced so we
want to take users out of the loop so
that the burden is not on them to report
violative content but to find it
ourselves and make sure that we can
proactively take it down so these are
kind of high level but I wanted to get
into more details of how this works for
a particular project that we've been
more public about and and this is
suspension evasion so let's say you're a
bad person on the internet and you do
something so bad that we say that you
are suspended from the platform once you
are suspended from the platform you are
no longer allowed to create new accounts
to go continue to proliferate your your
your abuse however you're a bad actor in
the Internet and so you're incentivized
to do this and you're like huh what
rules apply to me so you create a new
account it is up to us to detect these
users and then remediate them
appropriately so how does data science
fit in to this right there are many
different ways where we were involved
and this was like a really interesting
project because we were involved in
every step along the way I mentioned
earlier that I worked my first job was
an ad tech and I think ad tech gets a
like a bad rap because you know it's
like soulless and it's ruining the
internet but the thing about ad tech is
that it actually funds the Internet and
so there's part of it that like until
like new business models arise like ad
tech will always be part of the internet
and I do want to make a small defense
and in favor of attack and that's
because because it funds the internet it
has funding
an ad tech generates some of the largest
data sets on the Internet and so there
are actual interesting math problems in
this space and so one of the things that
I think you can do an ad Tech is you can
take the methods that you develop to
solve those problems and apply them to
other spaces and so one of the things
that I worked on and my first company
was entity resolution so finding out
which pieces of import information point
to the same entity or user and this is
something this is exactly what the
suspension evasion problem is you have a
user who's suspended and you need to
create some sort of linkage between that
suspended user and new accounts that
have been created by by the same person
and so data science was really critical
here because we needed to figure out
what of the matching algorithms did we
think performed best under whatever set
of metrics that we were were we're
considering how many entities can we
resolve using these matching algorithms
that we liked and then what are the
kinds of users that we catch with these
matching algorithms and I've drawn this
like little circle thing here because
they're all interrelated at some point
it's not just about you know you can't
always just like look at numbers and you
have the answer a lot of people talk
about like data science is making
data-driven thinking and I probably
actually have that in the slides here
somewhere too but in some ways you have
to be more data informed you can't
always be data-driven if you're purely
data-driven as as one of my friends who
used to work as a p.m. at Google used to
say there would be a porn tab in the
Google Image searches right so like you
have to also make these decisions based
on data with knowing what your product
is and and so for us on a data science
side in this project we needed to
understand and have an opinion over what
kinds of users we wanted to to catch so
like did people spew a bunch of like
hatred and violence and then go create a
new account to talk about their kids
soccer team or were they creating new
accounts to actually be abusive and it
turns out that they were creating
accounts to to proliferate they're very
bad world view
again after they'd been suspended so
once we figured out that there truly was
an opportunity and that these were the
ways in which that we wanted to tackle
the problem we needed to develop some
metrics to really figure out the ways in
which we are handling this are they
correct and so this is a lot more
prototyping and so whenever you develop
a metric not even just for this purpose
but in general you need to think about
several different things and this isn't
everything but these are somebody I
think the highlights does this metric
actually measure the purpose of the
product or the the workflow or the
whatever the thing that it is that
you're evaluating like how relevant is
it how does a metric move and is it
meaningful ways is it really noisy and
is it something where if there's any
exhaust effect that like it just goes up
and down like is it is it just like so
noisy and the variance is so high that
it's not meaningful does a metric not
move at all
and so sometimes you you have to ask
yourself do you want a leading indicator
or a lagging indicator right
what biases or assumptions are baked in
anytime you like do a select star from a
place you're making a choice and you're
baking in an assumption and it's
probably introducing some kind of bias
and you might want that bias right like
we want to understand what the people
that we think are doing bad things on
the Internet are doing right we don't
care to remediate users who are acting
in good faith in participating in
healthy ways right so like our bias is
to look at users who are abusive for
instance but you have to really ask
yourself when you're measuring things
like what what is it that you
assumptions are you making and how does
that change the outcome and then finally
I think from a business standpoint this
this last like kind of set of questions
is the difference between having fun
times with math and being an effective
data scientist is the metric
interpretable when I say this thing is
like twelve do people understand what
twelve means is it actionable
can you make
decisions from looking at that number
right like or is this just like a vanity
metric where you're patting yourself on
the back for like launching this thing
and then the other question that I think
is always important to ask is is it
gamble how would I like the the crafty
p.m. like guide the engineering team to
do a thing to like beat this metric and
look good even at the expense of some
other things and it's not always like a
bad thing if something is GameA below
that that also might mean that like it
goes back to the the point that like
metrics aren't always forever sometimes
you need to like update how you measure
things because your problem has changed
so my team is a team of data scientists
plus one longsuffering data engineer
who's very sad at our ability to use
JIRA and so the metric production
ization was like let's say like less
straightforward then then you would
imagine so our data scientist created an
ad hoc pipeline to gather data from
various sources in various ways using
various joins we used a side PI stack to
manipulate the pipeline data to try to
figure out like how we wanted to
construct our metrics and then we did an
evaluation to see which each of these
manipulations actually measured because
we had some some labels from like
different sources and once we settled on
like the way that we wanted to measure
the problem we needed production I use a
pipeline it turns out though that you
can't just like sort of throw things
like over the fence to engineering and
hope it all works out having a data
engineer or an engineering team that can
production eise's but also understands
like data and data science and metrics
is like really critical to making sure
that these systems work in the way that
you want them and so we worked really
closely with our data engineering team
to ensure that what we wanted to measure
was actually measure the way that we we
wanted and had prototype out as opposed
to making certain assumptions that like
can happen and how you joined data or
like how you do ratios
and stuff like that and so at the end
what it resulted in is we tweeted this
so we suspended accounts for attempting
to evade a suspension and we were able
to like have a really immediate and
important impact because we were able to
take these accounts off the platform to
make it better for the people who want
to be there to have these public
conversations so this brings me back to
this tweet
so again business we serve the public
conversation and as I look out into this
room and I I think about like what does
like the population of the world look
like this isn't particularly
representative right this is a bias
sample and I think that part of being
successful especially in a consumer
facing company is to make sure that you
truly can empathize with your users and
some of that means needing to have
better demographic representation of
your user base and the people who are
working day after day especially when
you're in the space of data science and
machine learning because the company is
making decisions like in an automated
fashion around things that will
definitely affect users and without
having the demographic representation of
your user base sometimes people just
forget so Twitter is really committed to
making sure that we are an inclusive and
diverse tech company and we say this is
how we'll serve the public conversation
but I think that it gets more to it it's
about making sure that like as a company
we really actually are here to serve our
users and to make sure that Twitter is
like almost like a public good is
something that can be used for everyone
Thanks
[Applause]
you